[Applause]
thank you for coming out to the free
show did you have a good Halloween at oh
no I guess it tough tough Halloween no
tough da stage Halloween this year in
Los Angeles because who needs a smoke
machine when you know we've got a bad
situation under 70 mile an hour winds
and every porch has a pumpkin with a
candle in it what could go no I
yesterday I was here on the what you
could smell smoke and for once it wasn't
me
it's sad but you know we're just in
California having to get used to this
right I mean I I heard someone today at
the coffee shop say I love your go-bag
Reggie get thank you well they're
evacuated perfect Palisades one of the
wealthiest communities in America they
evacuated them to the public schools out
there
they went there's a public school Lori
Loughlin today paid her kids to get into
a better shelter but let's not just
dwell on us it's a big country out there
and it was a big week Congress finally
did it they voted to formalize
impeachment here
it got zero Republican votes zero
Republicans think Trump has done
anything that's even worth checking out
yeah their view is they're outraged
they're Democrats are trying to overturn
the election and thwart the will of the
Russians no it's amazing they turn it
around like the Democrats they're using
Soviet style tactics there they're
staging a coup and yet the rules are
nearly identical to the ones that they
had in 1998 with a mph Bill Clinton the
this resolution lays out two clear rules
for public hearings requires a public
report on all findings authorizes the
sharing of all evidence Trump's lawyers
are allowed to be involved if it's a
coup it is the most magnanimous coup
I've ever seen in my life
the hearings Nancy Pelosi says they hope
to start right before Thanksgiving great
idea
get our Trump loving relatives at peak
panic mode right before we hand them the
giant carving knife
I mean now that the Trump people there
their view is that everyone else is
corrupt and human scum Donald Trump he's
the clean one everything about him reads
clean doesn't it he's not going anywhere
but a Democrat resigned this week Katie
hill from right right next county up yet
right I don't know what your we're gonna
talk about it but there were pretty
graphic pictures of her kissing women
and smoking a bong nude to it
exactly she was a representative of
California that's pretty
now President Trump ventured out of his
mumble this week and did not like it he
got booed at Game five of the World
Series as soon as he heard the booing in
the chanting he left early he ran back
to his Fox News and his rallies of
certified fans and his folder of
positive news clippings and then Tucker
Carlson came on TV and did an hour about
can you bleh
can you believe these college kids with
their safe spaces it was so close to not
[ __ ] that one up if you only knew how
delicate this job but now Trump has said
that he has had it with the East Coast
elitists he is changing his official
residency now to Florida you see that
Wow newsflash elderly New Yorker moves
to Florida
I am all for it
I think the headlines would just make a
lot more sense if you replace President
Trump with Florida man
Florida man starts pointless trade war
Florida man caught [ __ ] porn star at
golf tournament
Florida man drugs who did not eat your
jizz and then gives a full public
confession I mean it's just but
something happened just a couple hours
ruminant want to update you have been
busy all day better O'Rourke has dropped
out of the race he says he wants to
spend more time getting into a throuple
with Katy Hill okay
you